pop
[Musique]
mais on le surnomme le dinosaure du rock
35 ans de carrière plus de 500 chansons
dick rivers a traversé toutes les
époques parce qu'il a toujours été là on
a eu l'impression de le connaître mais
le plus discret de nos rockeurs traîne
derrière lui une tonne de clichés une
silhouette de cowboy une passion pour
elvis attention là il revendique c'est
bien le king qui a déterminé sa carrière
le jour où j'entends du elvis pour la
première fois j'ai eu un choc comme mode
des millions de gens à travers le monde
ont eu un choc qui ont commencé à mettre
un visage à cette époque il a 13 ans et
déjà le virus du rock'n'roll à 15 ans
dick rivers monte pour la première fois
sur scène c'est l'époque des chats
sauvages
oh
chic essaient de copier elvis mais très
vite il forge sa propre personnalité
début d'une carrière en solo les succès
s'enchaînent les rencontre aussi le
mythe et créons l'imaginent dans une
cadillac ou sur une harley moi je si je
prends une moto je fais dix mètres je me
pète la gueule je sais pas faire de moto
si je veux c'est piloter une 125
centimètres cube comme tout le monde
mais je veux dire des grosses motos des
douze centimètres cubes ou des monstres
comme ça je n'ai jamais eu pas de
collection de voitures américaines non
plus pas d'intérieur clinquant ni strass
ni paillettes les clichés tombent
que reste-t-il la seule chose qui est
véridique chez moi et que je porte
depuis l'âge de 13 ans qui est américain
et dont je suis fier et parce que je
suis bien dans ce sens mes bottes je me
demande même si j'ai des chaussures
normes entre mythe et réalité on
découvre alors un collectionneur de
gipson un amateurs de billard un
passionné de rodéo enfants spectateurs
le seul rodéo que j'ai fait j'ai fait
sur un label un de ses chevaux on met
des pièces de dents qui d'ailleurs est
assez musclé comme truc parce que ça
bouge dans tous les sens je le redis où
je ne serai pas faire ça aujourd'hui
l'amérique ne le fait plus rêver
mais fidèle à ses racines musicales
depuis 91 dick rivers enregistre ses
disques au texas à austin
loin du showbiz américain à 52 ans dick
est un homme heureux
authentique et véridique il avoué toute
sa vie à sa seule passion le rock'n'roll
comme bing com
[Musique]